welcome to this video playing against my
way from Norway and the sky is one of
the frequent opponents I have a terrible
score wow this really bad three wins
nine losses and I meet him and probably
all time low rating 21 I mean this guy
had 25 and 24 and 95 million chest so
it's quite quite low really okay this b3
business it looks weird but how to
actually make use of it very let's say
modern way to to try would be g5 here
just breaking up the the whole structure
but that's f 5 year yeah anyway come on
it's a it's the most principled way to
play oh that he played quickly but the
question is is it any good if I go if I
take and now that's various good good
ideas now taking night before for
example it could be one idea I can also
just take it okay let's start with
taking it
yeah that's good this guy is a really
good technical plan so I mean this is
position is very likely to be excellent
for black but it's not it's not the type
of position that you you love to have
against him because he's a very very
tricky I came anyway to get rid of this
active culinary I mean I can still take
and consider those counter place him my
g5 size is clear the only real idea I'd
like to get the the King out of out of
it okay let's try to get some counter
plane
night before there is maybe even night a
three and it's not clear what I'm doing
Queenie five maybe after that very very
tricky and already down by almost two
minutes okay so I need to speed up me
that's probably this is a kind of
position where i am can easily believe
that both sides are I in trouble okay
may six come on it you can give this
check i don't mind I'll take it and play
Knight f6 check nightie for is very
strong I mean on IG form depending on
what it does this looks very tricky now
okay the check or is there okay let's
let's start just check and now mr.
Knight the squeem e7 checkmate that said
something something to do not forget
maybe just go back I need to be quick
one minute fifty you will take on air
for probably and then then go green d6
know that should be ok for me really
I've got a pawn yes yeah I got bong pong
one extra porn and I'm not so far away
from castling long we should be seven
castles lankan be aid the dark squares
are tricky but ok it's got the King on
g1 and this is all not all not really
ideal night c2 and night a one and yeah
I can play a Quincy one and play Bishop
know what's the point I don't let a dead
rabbit I grab it the night on before
wasn't it wasn't this most stable peace
anyway
yeah and it's not he needs to misplace
PCM here Quincy six Quincy three years
my my idea getting getting the Queen's
off it's unavoidable really Queenie
three check made as a to bigger threat
yeah why it still has some vague
compensation it's not enough but there
is some some activity that that's good
I'd like to get rid of this this Bishop
which it's notoriously problematic yeah
that should be that really should be it
should be okay now for me check check
and f6
not even behind in development that much
at all hmm do I want to take I don't I
don't want to take so but anyway that's
okay brooksy to is a possibility this
check here can go here time warning yes
still go go to go to see to
I think you really only has a bunch of
checks try to get the King to the seven
maybe Luke g8 at age five something like
that he's said taking some time that's
really really good news nearing clock
clock wise i'm nearing his time came
maybe 9 f 2 was an option
check just take it take it all
just want to secure the king I now push
the pawns I can even take h2 I think I
don't see why not really we should be
six is not on not only for is doing a
good job of protecting check yeah okay
check check I've got stuff protected him
that's that's important everything's
nicely covered check check check white
resides yeah yet he had some some
compensation going I mean objectively
this is probably a this is opening is
probably very good for black but it's
it's it's just messy Knight f3 now not
sure really 93 if this was such a great
idea the computer points out here
killing one with an edge for white yeah
kind of move that stuff to make your TF
two oh wow hmm yeah
very nice the computer now wants to play
95 and black wins instantly very in very
nice move threatening 93 94 where that's
at so great and takes check this is very
nice now where where should the King go
now if you've tried to interpose there
is justice and then with this additional
threat like it's winning so after Bishop
takes LOL you can go here and then this
Bishop d7 coming possibly Bishop 5 and
the computer gives black a huge
advantage and not like not mother when I
was reading the display of it wrong with
black a substantially better okay I went
here 95 AC oops a 1696 is probably not
right but okay you went to be five to
give this check so it does not make much
sense for human to retreat so takes
takes Knight f6 check yeah and this is
so also what the computer suggest giving
black about a pawn of an advantage yeah
well I've a pawn up so this makes some
sense i guess the problem is well white
in a way it has a compensation
strategically as he's got the bishop
pair with the dark squared bishop being
quite quite a good piece potentially
because it's it's only dark squares
which are really weekend i have all
pawns on light square so the dark
squares are weak but well this is just
blundering 2 nite c 2 is the problem
maybe a computer once weeks wants to
trade even and play this position yeah
it should be sufficiently a stable for
black or a name it's not an easy win at
least not in blitz chess but
it should be a fairly good two extra
pawn yeah I'm just I'm just winning I
believe but it it did still take some
some precision ya can't think I allowed
anything anything too terrible yeah I
don't think after that there is anything
I'll be interested to look at yeah
probably this is not a good opening but
computer also wants to play g5
interesting alright thanks for watching